public school's a scam i mean it's it's
an indoctrination center that was
literally created on the foundations of
the rockefeller family that wanted good
slave workers that were going to be good
obedient workers in the factory
everything is based on that old
principle society doesn't run this way
anymore we don't have any factories the
rockefellers along with henry kissinger
and and nixon sent them over to china
when they opened up china to the rest of
the world but but but this is again a
failed system that is failing our
country our iqs have been going down
dramatically intelligence and and
emotional health has been going down
dramatically and i think this is done
deliberately and i think this is a
success of the system rather than a
failure because when you truly look at
how the system and why the system was
started it starts to make a lot more
sense that's exactly right i mean that's
where understanding that it was
developed in the industrial revolution
to say we want to have good factory
workers and what did we want we wanted
first of all to make sure they could go
tend the crops which is why we had
summers off so that they could attend
harvest